on va vous dévoiler les 30 candidates à
l'or il ya miss tahiti miss tahiti alors
on va parce que on va voir mistake qui
supplée cema paris bousquet elle a 22
ans elle fait remettre 80e alors qu'ils
misent sur elle dont il mit sur elle
merci bon on t'embrasse motards ishaq
doit son prénom
non mais c'est original et aux avis
entre adore se prénommerait s'appelle
matin à rimouski ressemble trop à iris
met une heure alors moi mon personnage
c'est pas du tout mon délire et insu
c'est une jolie femme feu sur il ya
lucide moines miss champagne me
champagne ardenne f 1 m 73 elle a 18 ans
diop et cie ou peu non le chinois les
jeudis alors lui témoigner hier soir
l'hapoël this new way we monde du disque
quoi elle pourrait vendre du disque que
tu prends rentrer chez plus de six mois
demi champagne 1 m 73 18 ans très me
mets pas mon délire non moi personne à
quelqu'un qu'est ce que l'on me dit
quand vous en faites une immense et nous
vous en faites une de vos favorites vous
me dites chez vous aussi bien que moi je
tais tu étais très développés dits
d'accord
flas florentina miss nord pas de calais
c'est florentina oui ah oui florentine
somers a way favorite alors favorite
pour vous oui favori lee ce traité
d'idiot sur un dîner favorite le faire
un peu de la météo de miss météo à
l'époque j'allais très joli hâle un
sourire magnifique et voilà je la trouve
à vous en faites sont favorites voici
oui moi aussi option alors est ferme et
elle a 19 ans florentine membres premium
pas du tout contre nous et chances de
régence pas mon délire pas mon délire
mais très jolie femme il ya miss mais
issam heures qu'il a sur le mile la
soeur de mike est miss auvergne 21
aurait alors il a l'air plus dark à moi
j'aime bien c'est la mission vous misez
sur sur miss auvergne beaucoup de charme
ouais c'est vrai que ça rigole où elle
pleure alors c'est ça mon délire voilà
mes chocolats
elle doit être sympathique aller à
l'aller remis ça peut ranquet drôle tu
vois voilà hausse quoi voilà n'a pas
l'air vachement rock and roll band and
mail pas d'être sympathique baisse est
moins attentive et dovi dit la
productrice de l'émission
j'ai plus pouvoir dire
alors oui à yako et prost alors elle est
arrivée c'est miss rhône alpes va faire
une vanne sur le volant alors jamais
jamais c'est la préférée de quelqu'un
chloé prost moi ça a failli quand ça a
failli alors on va voir les préférées
alors il ya aussi sur l'aisne bernard
dort n'égale miss franche-comté regard
des 1 m 75 23 ans
on adore moi je peux faire ça dit serein
j'adore les cochons mais sinon non les
mecs vous avez vu ce qu'on fait là c'est
quand même fort et ma voiture non mais
c'est sa pensée c'est horrible on est là
oui non oui non mais t'as vu ta tatouage
et de maquillage
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
faites un vote entre lui et moi elle est
très motivée même ramène aussi les deux
sont des nabots les deux sont très très
bon alors je vous le dit pas mais mine
de rien c'est vrai qu'on construit ce
qui va se passer le jour
c'est un concours de beauté absolue
alors gala yala préféré john kelly qui
arrive c'est miss provence 18 ans 1 m 71
la lra mort pas sur instagram alémanique
non c'est les photos le photo caméra
blanc fait vous j'ai compris votre
technique franchement vous voulez pas
qu'on vous lisez ou oui ce n'est pas
très clair un orthophoniste longueur
parce que j'ai projet invite la france à
aller voir sur instagram dans l'autre ça
va très bien non mais alors c'est votre
préférée et aux miss provence on la
suivra
quelle est la miss préférée de jimmy
c'est miss côte d'azur c'est manel
souahlia manel soual elle est jolie
en fait jusqu'à ce que le même prénom
que ma femme fatale man m non ce qu'il a
dit
et oui
[Applaudissements]
après il ya alors y est la préférée de
benjamin et d'isabelle c'est miss alsace
hamas à m'angoisser laura théodorit
alors la photo je vous le dis je vous
rejoins sur ces je vous rejoins si j'ai
rien c'est du maquillage siouplaît
théodorit miss alsace 23 ans 1 m 75
bien franchement très je la trouve très
jolie à l'arrêt ça c'est votre style je
vous rejoins non c'est pas du tout
d'accord saturé minuit le chien est soit
du tout taisez vous taisez vous un peu
tiens d'ailleurs on va voir préférer ses
marines clautour miss normandie exact 21
ans 1 m 72
elle est mignonne elle est soit elle est
quelque chose et l'espace n'est pas la
plus jolie
c'est un peu plus basse est rien réponse
j'ai rien dit elle est très jolie ne pas
faire ça le à sec était très classique
total et well as quelque chose autre on
sait pas quoi elle est très jolie très
riche ce que vous faites là c'est
horrible c'est vous qui l'avez mission
mais pas du tout mais alors mes préférés
séquelles alors monsieur jay chou les
regarde même pas de six icônes et nord
pas de calais je les regarde même pas
pas du tout alors il ya miss bretagne
romane edern c'était la préférée de
mathieu de l'embout ils ont regardé la
cérémonie et et s'arrêter là des de
l'année 1 m 73 24 on voit là et il ya
plein alors il ya miss martinique aussi
qui est très jolie ambre bose à regarder
voilà qui est très jolie ils sont en
train de chercher la voie la malaria
nakamura est là quelque chose
elle a trouvé là une classe et moi ma
petite préférée
je vous le dis c'est pas mon délit c'est
miss nouvelle calédonie c'est anaïs
thommen jeu j'ai dit ça au hasard me
suis pas encore allé jolies mèches
solaris calédonie ils sont tombés mais
leoni je vous le dis j'ai dit ça au
hasard mais je le sens vous avez ça tout
à fait magnifique